listen to this Bill Maher a guy known to
say a lot of controversial things often
pissing off a lot of people most
recently with this comment about Islam
it's the only religion that acts like
the Mafia that will fucking kill you
that you say the wrong thing draw the
wrong picture or write the wrong boy and
now he's bringing that controversy to UC
Berkeley where he's invited to be the
fall graduation speaker something a
group of students are actively trying to
stop
I'm with Raja and Miriam two of the
students spearheading the campaign to
drop bill maher as a commencement
speaker
why don't you guys want him to come
speak here the problem isn't like
telling him to stop speaking I mean he's
free to criticize religion he's free to
criticize whatever he wants to do but
the problem is that if he's going to
make these generalizations about a group
of people which are problematic and
dangerous then he doesn't deserve to be
elevated to the position of a
commencement speaker if he's free to
come to campus and he's free to come and
speak in a public forum in a debate but
not in this specific forum of the
commencement speech you guys say Bill
Maher is a blatant bigoted and racist
who has no respect for the values UC
Berkeley students and administration's
stand for isn't one of the core values
that UC Berkeley stands for free speech
I mean we're looking at the 50th
anniversary of the Free Speech Movement
the birthplace of which was Cal
we're sitting right now at the Free
Speech Movement cafe what do you say to
people who say you guys are actually
suppressing Bill Maher's free speech he
has his own TV show where he talks to
what he wants we're not stopping that at
all so he definitely has his avenues and
his venues to speak as much as he wants
you we've said countless times that we
are not violating his freedom of speech
in fact I would argue that the students
freedom of speech is being shut down by
elevating his voice in that respect oh
so you're still free to protest you're
free to write op-eds you're free to do a
change.org position how's your freedom
of speech being attacked by him Conner
three noes are just being attacked
because you're putting him in a setting
where we can't even question back we can
make it we can write op-eds we can
protest but a commencement speech isn't
set up to have dialogue and that's where
the problem lies
no at the end of the day he is a
comedian right so he takes jobs on a lot
of people he's made jokes about disabled
children dogs are like retarded children
he's made jokes about black pee
I thought when we elected a black
president we were gonna get a black
president I want him in a meeting with
the BP CEOs you know where he lifts up
his shirt so they could see the gun in
this thing are any of these groups
coming in solidarity with you guys to
stop him from speaking here yeah these
students agree with us they understand
that this is like a chance to stand in
solidarity with another group or
historically marginalized group like
it's a campus-wide movement it's not
just like let's say MSA it's not just
time they say there are students from
all backgrounds all walks of life who
agree that Bill Maher should not be
brought to campus that pressure led the
student group that initially chose Bill
Maher as the speaker to try to rescind
the invitation but the University
released a statement saying the
invitation still stands and that the
university has not in the past and will
not in the future shy away from hosting
speakers who some deem provocative what
message does that send to you guys I
mean for me like that's a clear message
saying that we've spent all these hours
these years discussing trying to fix
like how trying to fix campus climate
trying to address your issues and we're
gonna throw all that discussion out the
window and we're gonna invite someone
who is like the great if you're like a
prime example of how and why
Islamophobia exists not only does the
Muslim world have something in common
with Isis it has too much in common with
Isis if you're gonna say that all
Muslims are violent the average American
is going to look at that and they're
going to and they're going to take that
into their you know average like
knowledge of Muslims and every time you
see a Muslim you attach the word
violence you attach the word terrorist
but he's not talking to the average
Americans right he's talking to a
graduating class at UC Berkeley you guys
are hailed as some of the most critical
thinkers of your generation so don't you
give them at least the credit enough to
listen to his speech and make their own
decisions for themselves if you are like
you know one of the best critical
thinkers as you're saying shouldn't we
get someone who who himself or herself
is also a critical thinker or not
someone who just paints like broad
generalizations of people talk to me a
little bit about the campus climate here
for Muslim students like yourselves I
sit in class and I am basically forced
to defend myself because I am assumed to
be a supporter of Isis you wear a hijab
when you walk on campus you're targeted
on a day to day basis people come up to
me and they're like
oh so do you support terrorism does your
religion encourage this do you like they
come up to me and they're like oh are
you oppressed let me help you honey and
we have to deal with it on a day-to-day
basis
Berkeley also has a legacy of raising up
those and sending up for those who don't
who can't stand for themselves you know
we stand for values and one of those is
not marginalizing is stopping the
marginalization of different minorities
and different groups of people in
essence that's what we're fighting for
today
ya want more download the AJ plus mobile
app and join the conversation available
in your App Store now